Hi, I'm Erik Voss, and we've been getting
new updates about the upcoming Venom
movie, with spider-man's best villain
getting his own solo film produced by
Sony.
Tom Hardy will be playing Venom slash
Eddie Brock, and freaking Carnage is going
to be playing the villain. So venom and
Carnage together in a movie is a huge
deal, and this is probably why Sony
announced that this movie will
definitely be rated R. And this R
rating is interesting, because it brings
into question how Venom and Carnage
could ever fit into the overall
cinematic universe of Marvel characters,
with the MCU known as pretty
family-friendly versions of these
superheroes and villains.
Now even though Sony and Marvel Studios
are partnering to allow spider-man as a
character to cross over into the MCU, and
with movies like Spider-man: Homecoming,
Marvel head, Kevin Feige, has made it
clear that this will not be the case for
the Venom movie. So it sounds like Venom
and Carnage will be in their own
separate movie universe, where maybe
spider-man might appear, according to Amy
Pascal of Sony, but Venom won't appear in
scenes with or even really reference MCU
characters like Iron Man, Captain
America, Thor or Hulk. Now at first this
seems like kind of a bummer, because
these guys have a lot of fun
interactions with all these other Marvel
characters in the comics, but I think
this could ultimately be a good thing.
Why? Because Venom needs to have an R
rating. He is a violent, monstrous killer,
Carnage even more so, and I just don't
see Marvel Studios, in the direction that
it's currently going, being willing to
adapt Venom and Carnage to screen in
their true terrifying forms. So let's
talk about Venom and Carnage, why they're
such great villains, and why keeping them
out of the Marvel side of the Cinematic
Universe might be the best thing for
them. And potential spoiler warning, in
case any of my speculation with stuff
from the comics ends up being in the
movie. So let's start with a little
background on Venom. Venom comes from an
alien race of symbiotes who, in the comics,
he attaches himself to Spider-man when
he was in Battle World, which is a big
melee with a ton of different
superheroes and villains. So Peter's suit
was damaged and the symbiote covered his
body, giving him this new awesome black
suit with a white logo. It also had a
shape-shifting ability, allowing him to
mimic wearing street clothes, and gave
him an unlimited and stronger supply of
webbing. But then Peter learned that the
symbiote was really a parasite that
eventually drains all the adrenaline
from its host, so he detached it using
the
sonic waves from the bells in a church
bell tower. And then the symbiote
sought out another person who hated
Peter Parker, ex-journalist Eddie Brock,
who's career Peter ended. And it merged
with Eddie Brock, creating Venom. Now
some of this backstory was adapted for
the version of Venom that we saw in
Spider-man 3 with Topher Grace, and
unfortunately that movie didn't really
do nearly enough with the character.
Spider-man 3 really just mostly stuck
with Peter's relationship with a symbiote,
which turned him into a kind of pervy
dancer, with the Eddie Brock / Venom
subplots getting lost in Peter's conflicts
with Harry Osborn and Sandman. And as
much as I love to watch James Franco
eating pie, I'd rather see Venom do some
messed-up shit.
And this is why I'm excited about this
R-rated Venom movie. Venom is savage, a
big part of its popularity is that he's
very much a bizarro version of
Spider-man (and sorry to mix in a DC
reference in there.) Like Peter Parker is
super friendly, and neighborhoody! He's a
kid, he cracks jokes, but Venom is a total
monster. Since he previously bonded with
Spider-man as a symbiote, all later
versions of Venom have Spider-man's powers, too.
He's a lot stronger, and he's a
shapeshifter,
and he's invisible to Spider-man's spidey
sense, making him a serious threat. In
fact in the comics, he's considered by
Shield to be one of the biggest dangers
to all of humanity,
up there with Magneto and Dr. Doom. And
already, you just can't do that character
justice with a PG-13 MCU type movie that
you would take little kids to go see.
Unless you want them to grow up to be
cool. And the director currently attached
to Venom is Ruben Fleischer, who directed
Zombieland, and I really hope that he
brings that same dark, violent sense of
humor to this movie, too. Now I actually
kind of like Sam Raimi's design of the
symbiote in Spider-man 3, but I think
Fleischer can build on that to make
Venom even more monstrous and
stomach-turning. I'm just going to give
you a few examples of some of the
sickening stuff that Venom has done in
various versions of the comics. 1. Later
host of Venom, Mac Gargan formerly the
Scorpion, isn't as good as Eddie Brock is
at controlling the symbiote, so he gives
into some of the more animalistic urges,
specifically cannibalism. Yes,
Venom freaking eats people. And that same
version of Venom also gets in a fight
with Bullseye, who throws a small dog into
Venom's eye, and Venom continues fighting
with the dog sticking out of his eye,
until later he pops it out and chucks it.
Now another version of Venom detaches
from a host who's a mobster's son, Angelo
Fortunato.
In the middle of a jump between
buildings, he lets the guy fall to his
death. Then there's a really bad version
of the Venom comics from the mid-2000s,
where Venom fights with the Thing from
the Fantastic Four, and he kills him by
sticking his long tongue down his throat.
And then there's another alternate
series of Marvel comics called What If,
where the Battle World arc that I
mentioned earlier goes a different way,
and Spider-man is on a planet with his
symbiote black suit, but then he gets
hit with a sonic blast and the symbiote
detaches from Peter Parker's skeleton.
That's right, Peter Parker had been dead
for years and the symbiote form of Venom
was just Weekend at Bernie-ing his
corpse all this time! But really, it's not
just this insane, creative violence that
makes Venom a more adult character, and
yeah it isn't profanity either... it's the
sex. I'm kidding guys, I really don't want
to see Venom have sex.
I really shouldn't've brought up that
example... with the Thing. Really, it's the
deeper psychological component of Venom
as a character. Now as a symbiote bonded
with a host, there's kind of a split
personality competing for control of
Eddie Brock's mind. It's a toxic balance
of the two organisms' hatred feeding and
enabling each other. And that was another
element that the Spider-man 3 Venom just
didn't have enough time to go into.
And really, I don't know how far the MCU
would be willing to explore that kind of
psychological disorder. Like Iron Man 3
kind of touched on Tony Stark's PTSD
from the Battle of New York, and
I guess Doctor Strange looked at
Stephen's depression after his car accident,
but the competing voices in Eddie
Brock's head are something that he has
to deal with in a very physical way, and
that's a conflict that's going to take a
lot of maturity and patience to convey
on screen. For example, look at Logan.
Director James Mangold said that the R
rating for that movie wasn't just so he
could show Wolverine clawing through skulls,
even though that was very cool and I'm
glad I got to see it. Mangold said that
he wanted to explore characters and
relationships in a way that didn't also
have to please audiences with shorter
attention spans. So that's why huge
sections of Logan simply focused on the
mental, emotional, and physical toll that
superpowers have taken on Logan and
Charles. They're people, not toys. They get
sick, they aren't always likable, and
spoiler alert - seriously, stop watching if
you haven't seen Logan -
they kiss! Just kidding, they die. Now I
don't always need my superhero
movies to go that deep into a
character's psychological trauma. Like Thor
Ragnarok looks like ridiculous fun, and I
would be kind of bummed if it ever got
this serious, but in Venom's case, yeah, I
really think it needs to be more
emotionally complex. And I really think
Tom Hardy is perfect for that kind of
raw, physical role. He's a serious actor
who puts his whole body into a
performance. I just hope that for this
superhero villain he'll pick a
different voice. Your spidey sense won't
save you now,
Parker. But let's move on to Carnage, the
villain of this movie. Yeah, that's right,
Carnage is so awful that even Venom sees
him as a threat that needs to be
stopped. So a little background on
Carnage in the comics. So Carnage is the
asexual offspring of Venom's symbiote. And
it attaches to Cletus Kasady,
who's a serial killer whom Eddie Brock
shares a prison cell with. And Kasady is
already totally evil. As a kid, he
tortured his family dog with an electric
drill, and he killed his grandmother by
pushing her down a flight of stairs. He
also burned down the boys home that he
was forced to live in. So when Kasady
becomes Carnage he just goes on
straight-up killing sprees, just to get
Spider-man's attention, and really,
because he just feels like it. He murders
one of Peter Parker's classmates, and he
can shape-shift his arms into cutting
weapons, slicing and impaling the bodies
of innocent bystanders on the street and
in diners. He attacks a little kid and a
baby in a bathtub, and he kills people
through computer screens, and he
constantly fantasizes about mutilating
Peter Parker. So really, as intense as
Venom is, Carnage is way more extreme, and
again, there's just no way this would
work in anything less than an R
rating. So if Sony really plans to go in
this direction with a darker, more adult
superhero movie universe separate from
the family-friendly MCU, they're really
right to set the tone early with this
Venom movie. It really is the best way to
be true to what fans love from the
comics. Do you think a movie version of
Venom that will never cross paths with
Iron Man or Captain America or Hulk or
for that matter, Daredevil or Punisher, is
worth its own movie universe if that
universe gets to be dark, adult and
violent? And do you think Venom should
use this R rating for more extreme
violence? Or to explore that kind of
psychological trauma stuff on a level
that younger audiences just might not
appreciate? Let me know what you think in
the comments down below and share this
video on Twitter. You can tweet your
thoughts directly to me (@eavoss) or to
new rockstars (@newrockstars). And
subscribe to new rockstars on this
channel to keep up with all of our
videos about Spider-man and the Marvel
movies. You can also contribute to us on
patreon to be more part of our team, and
to have more say in what videos we make,
and to access exclusive content on our
page. Big thanks to our patron Kelly
Hopper. Thanks for watching, and... ugh. I just
thought about the kiss
again... god, I can't unsee it!